let's see let's go to our caller from
the 3-1 to area code who's calling today
from three one two hello yes hi Hugh
from Illinois hey how's it going
I I have a subject I want to bring up is
about great a Sundberg okay just one the
person of the year for time right now
right and there's the questions I have
is like a two-parter I don't know if it
was inspired like is inspired by Trump
or I don't know whatever else but the
way that she's been been treated in the
Internet is kind of just worried so how
people just talk about this girl and I
just the first question is why do you
think people treat her that way my
second question is why did time make her
personal the year so the second part
first I my sense I don't I'm not saying
she didn't deserve it or she did deserve
it I think the whole concept of Person
of the Year on a planet with 7 billion
people is a dubious concept anyway but
let's ignore that for a second I've
always perceived that time has a sense
of humor or a sense of satire or a sense
of trolling when they do Person of the
Year so part of me does suggest you know
Trump has made a huge deal out of he's
lied about the number of times he's been
on the cover of time for example I kind
of get the sense that there's a little
bit of a let's trigger Trump element of
selecting Greta Thun Berg as Person of
the Year
you know we every year there are
probably millions of people that are
you're certainly tens of thousands that
would be a strong contender for Person
of the Year many of which we'll never
hear about because we have a country of
you know planet of 200 countries and 7
billion people getting closer and closer
to to 8 billion people now as far as the
treatment of Greta online it's
absolutely disgusting I mean you're
talking here about first of all you're
talking about a kid now you can say well
it's a kid but she's choosing to be in
the public eye and she's doing things to
get attention and therefore there is
going to be reaction and the reaction if
people are allowed to evaluate what
she's doing sure evaluate what she's
doing on the facts evaluate you know the
of what she's trying to do but you know
making fun of her for being autistic
either implicitly or explicitly is a big
theme that I see online and it's
absolutely disgusting ridiculing her
demeanor
we're talking about someone who even if
you don't agree with her about the facts
about the IceCaps right we are talking
about someone who has the best
intentions and is a kid in the end and
it is disgusting what you see happening
online about her yeah and I see a lot of
a big subject that everybody brings up
whenever they try to crash on her is
that it's her parents that like pay
everything and just use her as a coaster
as opposed her child for the whole
movement well who's a kid honey yeah
yeah it's just do you think that's
justifiable at like if her parents
really coerced her into doing into being
the this symbol for climate change or
mean listen I don't know what that means
there's no question you know my politics
and my interests have been heavily
influenced by those of my parents did
they coerce me no did they encourage me
to do things I showed an interest in of
course yeah the idea that greta toon
burg is essentially a slave held hostage
by her parents to do climate activism
seems laughable there's no question that
she got into this because of her parents
that's sort of how life works if you're
connected to your parents and they're
raising you in a home where you talk and
are involved with each other again it
just people are really looking people
are very triggered by her and they start
doing things that make very little sense
yeah yeah that's all they think for the
answer did they yeah I don't know he
just has me worried so inside so I just
need to I need some kind of voice of
reason all right thank you so much I
appreciate the phone call very much
let's take a quick break if you're
holding don't hang up because we are
going right back to the phones after
this very very short break